get a load it in
Spider-Man can't show up to court and
he's webbed to the robberies got him up
against the wall with a little sign that
says from your friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man if all they have is
Spider-Man's note that's not going to be
enough to convict him my name is Doug
Ridley and I'm a criminal defense
attorney
you know when I first watched that film
I was feeling very sympathetic towards
Peter it's just an innocent mistake that
this guy accidentally trips over a pipe
and goes out the window but if I'm
really looking at this and really
analyzing it from a criminal law
standpoint Peter goes there to beat this
guy up he is going there to beat up the
guy that killed his uncle he's not going
over there to apprehend him he goes in
there and starts beating on him right
away and if he's going there to commit a
felony to assault this person whether he
deserves it or not and the person dies
Peter is actually good for murder
legally he's good for the results of
that whole battle and unintentioned or
not I'm so sorry Peter but you're good
for murder he's a criminal actually is
the glider scene is really interesting
when he jumps out of the way he's not
changing the trajectory of the glider he
is literally just getting out of the way
so I think Peter has zero liability for
what happens to Norman Osborne even
though Harry can't quite accept that I
swear on my father's grave Spider-Man
will pay
[Music]
our general right of self-defense is
that we're allowed to use equal force to
protect ourselves so somebody punches me
I don't have the ability to shoot them
right in the head I have the ability to
use equal force back Peter stops the
bomb from going at him but then he
intentionally whips it right back at
Harry so the self-defense argument would
have had to have been that Peter somehow
was stopping Harry from grabbing a
second a third or a fourth pumpkin bomb
and so therefore it was equal force
Peter after the strawberry line that
Harry says about kissing MJ strawberry
just hauls off and socks him right in
the mouth the person that starts the
fight really has a hard time of claiming
self-defense for everything else that
happens from there and then we can pause
it at the moment where Harry brings out
the sword or dagger or whatever it is
and stabs Peter right in his stomach
Harry wouldn't have right to
self-defense to have more Force being
used they keep escalating and so none of
them are in the right through the whole
thing I've also seen cases where
prosecutors just throw out their hands
and say this is a mutual combat
situation and neither of them is a true
victim or a true defendant I'm gonna Cry
Sometimes on lesser level fights that
don't involve pumpkin bombs they might
just let the whole thing go away because
it's mutual combat
come on
the Symbiote aspect of what's going on
with Peter uh Mr Rainey did a fantastic
job of this drug addiction allegory
that's going on here layered over with
some mental health issues if someone
really truly has a major addiction
they're not completely let off the hook
for the crimes they commit while they're
under the influence of drugs or or other
substances but it definitely is a factor
that we can argue to try to reduce our
sentence or try to reduce the charges in
some way someone who has a true multiple
personality disorder and has a
significant mental health issue here in
California at least we have a new
diversion statute that allows people to
get treatment for their mental health
issues and avoid criminal prosecution
completely so I would love to put emo
Peter through the mental health program
and come up with a treatment plan
treatment plan apparently involves
bringing large bells and making Venom
leave him and if only if it was that
easy and real life
thank you
when Gwen Falls and doesn't survive the
fall there's going to be a question
there about whether or not he was
negligent in some way the word negligent
has a very specific legal meaning and
it's somebody not exercising the level
of care that they should otherwise and
if he was negligent it wouldn't be a
murder charge but it could be a
voluntary manslaughter charge we see
that sometimes if people are making bad
decisions when they're driving people
who are driving and somebody dies
sometimes are charged with vehicular
manslaughter or voluntary manslaughter
and so it's a similar analysis to that
very sad in those sorts of cases because
there's not truly a bad guy there's
someone who may not have exercised the
level of care that they were supposed to
I can't go to Germany why
homework
Tony Stark has a ton of liability for
everything that he is encouraging this
minor to do and we can use the examples
of situations where parents allow their
kids to use Firearms those parents are
liable for contributing to the
delinquency of a minor oh if I was
defending Peter I would have him roll on
Tony in a million in a minute no
question about it I would blame Tony all
day every day for everything bad that
happened to Peter
do it execute them all video footage has
always been used as primary evidence in
cases but this is a new time where we
can't always trust exactly what's going
on if we see it on video if we see it on
audio with the advancement of AI and how
all of that's going it casts a lot of
Doubt on evidence that we used to take
for granted there you have it folks
conclusive proof that Spider-Man was
responsible for the brutal murder of
Mysterio I would love to represent Peter
on a libel suit against Jay Jonah
Jameson and The Daily Bugle I don't know
that Peter would go for it here's the
challenge the rules on Libel and
defamation when it comes to public
figures are much different than a
regular citizen there's a much higher
threshold Peter Parker would have a case
but he wouldn't be able to do it as
Spider-Man Spider-Man is not a person so
when we file something in court it is
our legal names there is absolutely no
way that any judge in this country would
allow somebody to walk into their
courtroom with a mask on and take the
stand and not identify themselves by
their true and legal name
that's great thank you
well I have some good news Peter I don't
believe any of the charges against you
are going to stick I would love to be
able to tell you that I can get cases
resolved in the 15 minutes that it took
during the movie for Matt Murdoch to get
it done no matter how great Matt Murdoch
is as a lawyer there's definitely not
going to be a complete resolution of the
case that fast I will say however that
there have been a lot of times where
picking up the phone and having some
conversations definitely does sometimes
resolve cases
will is going on out there I keep
yelling at you I thought you were Peter
too what I'm not Peter stop arguing both
of you listen to Peter one if I had
somebody that came in and said that they
were from the Multiverse I mean if that
happened tomorrow I I'm going to have to
get them psychologically evaluated I
mean that that's just that that's just
the way that it has to be if we
establish for argument's sake that the
Multiverse exists I would absolutely
argue the multiversal theory I would
just not want to be the first person to
do that just